hey youtubers is charlie is going to be
my Constantine finale video we don't
have any confirmation on season 2 right
now but I'll try to explain where that
is I think the big twist at the end is a
good jumping off point for season 2 and
I'd be totally happy if they came back
for like 8 or 13 episodes as long as we
get more Constantine they've had free
reign in the supernatural corner of the
DC Universe and there's just so many
untapped places that they could go they
could do Trinity of sin they still
haven't done dr. fate and they've barely
gotten into the specter but let's just
start with top 5 moments so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet number 5
redneck Satanist is abducting brides so
what was going on is he was abducting a
new girl at every lunar eclipse
Constantine explained that it was the
fourth in a cycle - Blood Moon so by
sacrificing a new girl at every lunar
eclipse he was trying to usher in a
rebirth it's a little bit like Zed
storyline in the comics I'm glad that
they didn't kill her off I'm glad that
they dropped that storyline for now
they'll just resume it in season 2 if
they get picked up on to number 4 Jim
Corrigan is back on the case the reason
he's back is because the crimes were
happening in and around New Orleans I
always like seeing Emmett Scanlon back I
love the ship that they have going on
with him and said now I feel like they
haven't had quite enough time to develop
his character so in season 2 hopefully
they'll be able to spend more time with
them I totally understand why they
didn't turn him into Spectre at the end
of this episode it just feels like it's
too soon like they just now introduced
the main villain in the comics the
spectre is the spirit of vengeance so
first some crazy atrocity has to be
committed before vengeance is demanded
by God thankfully it seems like Manny's
gonna open that door pretty soon it did
seem a little misleading because Zed
kept having visions of him being dead
I think they included those just to
remind casual viewers that there is a
greater destiny coming for Jim Corrigan
anybody that's read a comic book knows
exactly what's going to happen to Jim
Corrigan but the shows are designed so
that people that don't read comic books
can follow them pretty easily that's
usually the key to getting renewed like
if you've never read a comic book and
you can still enjoy a TV show that's
that's really what they want to hit
moving on to number three Constantine
casts a tibetan spell to find the girl
this was just a lot of fun watching
Constantine shocked the hell out of
himself he explained like what it did is
it put it into a state between life and
death so that his spirit could travel
the path of the girl
I like the way they invoke mythology
from all over the world magic is very
international and very specific to
regions Papa midnite Sloot is another
really good example of a magic that's
very different from traditional
demonology typically this were like a
lot of help laser goes as demonology
just because you're dealing with heaven
and hell they use it for a little bit of
comedy I mean like he just blows right
through it like it's no big deal can you
just see him back in his punk-rock days
shocking himself just to get some sort
of high like do a bunch of drugs then
stick your finger in a light socket just
to see what happens if there's anything
I'd like to see him double down on in
season 2 it's funny moments like this
like I'm just going to kill myself for
about 10 seconds so I can find this girl
no big deal don't worry even though
he'll blazars a really dark comic book
there's no reason that constantine has
to be super depressing moving on to
number two Constantine versus Papa
midnite Michael James Shaw also one of
the best guest stars that the show has
he's not totally Constantine's enemy
he's just trying to save his sister and
this is the way to do it just to follow
the contract so the Brujeria took the
contract out on John Constantine's life
Papa midnite is trying to collect on
that contract
in exchange for Constantine they'll
bring his sister back from the dead I
was so happy that they were able to
bring back Gary Lester to warn him about
that too to warn him about the contract
that's actually a really cool easter egg
from the comics Gary Lester is one of
the ghosts that haunts constatine he
also gets haunted by a lot of his dead
girlfriends too it's kind of a bummer
but it can come in handy in situations
like this it's another one of those
things that you can expect to see more
of when we get to season 2 I'm just
gonna go ahead and speak like we're
getting season 2 like it's already said
and done even though that's not true and
finally my number 1 moment manny is
revealed as the big bad of the season so
here's something really important Harold
Perrineau the actor that plays Manny
confirmed he is not a character from the
comic books I was actually I was a
little confused I was trying to figure
out who he might be their number of big
demon characters all the way up to the
first of the Fallen
but that's Lucifer so if he were Lucifer
he basically be the devil and I don't
think that Manny is that powerful so
that's not who he is he seems more like
a rogue angel like he's not masquerading
as an angel he really really is an angel
I suspect he's something closer to the
fallen angel that we saw earlier this
season the one who found a way out of
heaven and if you watch Supernatural you
watch that TV show just think of the way
angels are depicted they're just because
they are beings of
heaven doesn't mean they can't do bad
things I don't know what God's role is
going to be in the Constantine universe
if it's gonna be like supernatural where
he's like off somewhere else never
coming back or if he's going to appear
at some point to create the Jim Corrigan
Spectre logically you think mani is
going to visit some atrocity on the
earth and as an answer to that God is
going to create the specter we really
haven't gotten to the point of the show
where we started to deal with
cosmological entities and that's really
where the specter is he literally is a
part of God
He is God spirit of vengeance so before
we get there we're going to spend some
time developing mani as the villain
typically that would start at the
mid-season finale like they make that
reveal like oh hey I'm the big bad and
then you'd find out what their plan was
the back half of the season but because
Constantine only got a short and run I
think they decided to hold that off and
use it for season to let me know that
what was your favorite moment from the
episode and where do you want to see
them take season 2 like what do you want
to see happen with Manny Constantine and
the spectre let's not forget we also
have the resurrection crusade plotline
they kind of drop that Matt Ryan
actually hinted that they might do
family man that that arc from the comic
books that's just where John tries to
track down a serial killer called the
family man it was written by Jamie
Delano which is actually an Easter Egg
from the episode that the house the
creepy house was on Delano Street so
goes into true crime true detective
supernatural territory if you want to
read more about that in the comics you
can actually buy that as a bundle on
comiXology
the family man it just it's a collected
trade paperback that collects all those
comic books as part of that storyline I
would say in the grand scheme of things
of all the different Constantine stories
the big story arcs that's one of the
best so I would check it out you start
to see in the Hellblazer comics is that
Constantine begins to view people as
being worse than the demons that he
usually fights it's really interesting
twist like real life is worse than hell
Constantine's ratings are actually
somewhere between the flash and arrow so
it actually gets better ratings than
arrow and arrow is almost guaranteed for
renewal every year every network's
different so I totally feel like the
show could survive on Sci Fi and that's
what the current rumor is that they're
going to move it to sci-fi it'll be
rebranded as Hellblazer and they'll have
a little more freedom to get fantastical
do more comic book type stuff that's
where we could get into Trinity of sin
Phantom Stranger Specter
dr. fate all the really cool stuff like
the cool adventure stuff that you want
to see there are a couple issues that I
feel like they could totally address
that would make the show a lot more fun
to watch and a lot easier for new
viewers one is to pick up the pace this
is a comic book show it moves way too
slow for that probably the best example
of the pacing a comic book show should
have is the flash right now that's why
it's so much fun to watch regardless of
what the story is or what the tone is
comic books move very fast and the
second thing would be to turn it into an
adventure based show and I kinda
mentioned that last week I feel like the
adventure tone also works much better in
the comic book genre those are just a
couple of things that I'd like to see
but you guys you guys can let me know if
there's any aspects of the show that you
would like to see them tweak a little
bit if they got a season two and
everyone really wants to know if they're
going to get renewed I think they're
going to wait a week or so hopefully by
tomorrow or by next week at least
they'll have an announcement like by
Monday or Tuesday and if they don't get
renewed it's totally possible that Matt
Brian could guest star on one of the
other DC TV shows as John Constantine
that would all be pending on
arrangements between networks but I
think it was totally possible
if NBC isn't going to renew the show I
don't think they would prevent the
character from appearing on another
network so while we all hold our breath
waiting for a Constantine season to
announcement you guys can click here to
catch up on arrow from this week and you
can click here to catch up on the flash
thank you so much for watching so let's
all high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you